let's move on to
uh number three all right so the third
one is the victim mindset
this is an interesting one so i'll put a
card up in the top right from my
experience dating a single mother you
should check that video out after you
finish watching this
i recorded it about four years ago and
one thing that you need to understand is
that
i have not come across a woman
that had children in tow from a prior
relationship that did not
subscribe to a victim mindset um
it's quite common in the narratives that
toxic feminism
uh suggests to women because the problem
with
that version of today's toxic feminism
is
it tends to encourage women uh to be
the uh victim like there's always some
oppressor holding them down
uh there's a patriarchy there's somebody
that's doing the exact same job
that's making a dollar for every 70 odd
cents that she earns
there's always some narrative around
that and if you're involved with
somebody that has a victim mindset
people with a victim mindset simply
cannot be happy they're always going to
be looking for an oppressor they're
always going to be looking for a villain
anybody seeking a villain a villain in
life is always going to have a hard time
with that now
you may not immediately be who she deems
to be that problem or that villain
for example but at some point in the
future you're a man
she's a woman and feminism isn't
particularly warm to masculinity in men
these days if you haven't noticed
you need to be aware that there's going
to be issues with victim mindset
now that's not just something you're
going to have to deal with with her
you're also going to end up dealing with
it with her children let me give you a
good example
so we talked earlier about authority
without responsibility
if you want to exercise some authority
let's say and enforce some boundaries
let's say her kids are behaving badly
maybe they're becoming bratty
they're maybe a little entitled there's
something that requires
some you know reeling in you know you
got to put some boundaries around it and
you try to enforce them
a lot of the times because her mom
already because the
kid's mom already subscribes to a victim
mindset
they're automatically going to default
to that because that's what they know
their children they don't know any
better
right they're they're always a product
of their environment so if
mom subscribes to a victim mindset has
issues with
patriarchy or whatever narrative that
she might be using her ex is a bum
he is a loser which is an interesting
thing by the way because
uh she's the one that picked him you
know at the end of the day she's the one
that decided to you know it's men that
propose to women and she says i do so
why would she do that but that's a
that's an entirely different topic but
at the end of the day the kids will also
use nearly the same strategy
uh on their mom and then again that's
when you'll find that you know
you you've got kids that are no longer
ours but they're now
hers and when you try to enforce
boundaries the emotional manipulation
that comes out of that with her
with her kids is going to be problematic
for you it's going to be exhausting
you